Okay, fine.
The world
will get more invincible in late 2023.
All right.
Okay, I'll take it.
Late 2023.
Perfect, sir.
So 2023.
Is that like, one of your years?
You know, our planet,
they all have different systems
of keeping track of time.
Like they go around their stars,
different speed.
But the way you set that number makes it
sound.
Suit is a tune
I really want it to be, sir.
Welcome back,
everyone. Is Charlie Invincible?
Just released a season two teaser trailer
and a teaser for Jeffrey Dean
Morgan joining the show. I'll explain
what's going on.
There's also a live action
invincible movie
that Robert Kirkman is making separately,
but it's like a totally different thing.
Jeffrey Dean
Morgan could also be joining for that.
I'll explain that as well.
But the character that he's playing
is meant to be the most powerful character
in the series.
And like the main antagonist
for the entire series.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll be doing videos for all the season
two episodes when it premieres,
and I'll do a special giveaway
for all those too many.
Thanks to this week's sponsors Raid.
Shadow Legend Read Shadow
Legends is one of the biggest
mobile games in the world right now
that's totally free to play.
To kick off the New Year,
they released an update
with a bunch of new features,
including a new season of the Forge Pass,
the Period Points program,
which allows you to earn in-game
prizes, including a legendary champion
in a bunch more.
There's also a ton of new champions
they're introducing, including Kellen
The Shrike and Edna Moonbeam,
who are part of a whole new faction
they've introduced
called the Sylvan Watchers.
They just added a legendary champion
based on MMO superstar Ronda
Rousey, with fighting moves based on her
real life MMA fighting techniques.
You can get Ronda for free right now.
All you have to do is log in
and play rate for seven days
between now and February 28.
Use a special promo code raid. Ronda.
I'll put her on screen here
to get a bunch of helpful stuff
and because Raid is having its fourth
anniversary later
this year,
they're launching a special Titan event.
It'll be live for several weeks.
During it, you can earn anniversary points
by competing in special themed events
and win some really cool rewards
for brand new players in the U.S.
raids.
Also giving away in-game in real life
prizes, including a chance to win
an Amazon gift card worth up to $1,000
as part of a special contest
they're holding where you vote
for your favorite starter champion.
Go to Champion select player
Yen.com.gh and enter your player ID.
I'll put the link on screen here
and vote for your chosen champion.
The vote ends February 10th.
One champion will be crowned winner and
prize winners will be selected via draw.
For existing players, you can also get
some free stuff by going to that same link
where you get a special promo code
that you can use for an in-game gift.
New players can use my link
or scan the QR code
right here to get a free starter
pack with this cool in-game loot.
Your rewards will be in your inbox here,
so be sure to vote on your favorite
starter champion for a chance to win.
But in his post here,
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is reading Invincible
Compendium two and three.
There is that live action invincible movie
that Robert Kirkman teased.
I said, they're making that will happen
for a couple more years.
We'll get a couple more seasons
of the animated show, season two
and season three before that happens,
which is why I say this is mostly
probably a teaser for the animated series,
not for the live action movie,
but he could also be playing a character
in the live action movie, like he'd
make an amazing live action omni-man
because he's about the right age.
He's got the right look for it.
Even though J.K.
Simmons is amazing
as the animated omni-man
and he can get swole like he did
get swole for a Chris Pratt movie
a couple of years ago.
So he can get huge if he wants to.
The actual teaser here that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan was dropping is meant to be
that he's playing the character from later
in the story because Compendium two
and three cover everything from issue
48 to the end of the story.
And he's probably
playing the main antagonist of the series,
like he typically only plays
really big characters
and he's been playing Negan on The Walking
Dead, one of the overarching villains
for the entire series
to make the Robert Kirkman connection
because Robert Kirkman created Invincible
and he created The Walking Dead.
So naturally
he would go to his friends to play
really big characters on Invincible.
So that's why Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is probably cast to play Thragg.
Now, he's not totally unkillable,
but he is meant to be
the most powerful vulture
might that exists,
even though Mark's name is invincible
and it's kind of tongue in cheek,
he is functionally invincible
compared to everyone else in the universe.
Even though it seemed like Battle
Beast was almost able to kill him,
Omni-Man stopped him from doing that.
That's mostly
just because Mark was inexperienced.
Like he just wasn't
a good fighter to begin with.
One of the big things about vulture mites
is that really the only thing
that can kill a vulture might is
another vulture might in the scourge
virus, which I'll explain
because it has to do with rags backstory.
He's the current
leader of the vulture mites, the person
giving them all their marching orders
as they continue to conquer the universe
and replenish their race,
replenish their ranks, so to speak.
And even though he's the ruler
of their people, they do have an empire.
Historically. He is not the emperor.
He is actually the regent.
They tease a little bit
about the Viltrumites backstory,
their race when Omni-Man was telling Mark
and then later Alan,
the alien told him about it separately.
You continue to learn more
about the history of their race
from other new characters
that will meet during season
two and beyond.
But the Viltrumites
are meant to be like the Kryptonians
in the Superman DC movies
or the scenes in the Dragon Ball universe.
The scenes are probably
a more accurate depiction.
But when Robert Kirkman created
the Invincible
comic book, he was inspired
more by the Superman characters
than he was by the Dragon Ball
characters, a race of beings
that are so naturally powerful
they go around
conquering the rest of the universe.
But they didn't start out that way.
The viltrumites started out as a normal
humanoid, raised normal power levels,
nothing too special about them.
Like any other race over the centuries,
they dedicated themselves
to just making themselves more powerful,
evolving all these natural abilities
that you see in present day
constant battles, genetic breeding
programs, mostly a lot of genetic breeding
until they became ultra powerful.
When that started to happen, they started
conquering other worlds the old fashioned
way, their armies sweeping
around the universe, conquering systems.
At that point,
their emperor was a man named Oracle.
A man named Thaddeus came along and said,
You know what?
What if we didn't conquer the rest of the
universe and subjugate all these people?
He led a faction within their race
to start what they called the victor.
Might civil War over whether or not
they should be a conquering race.
There was a faction of them
that wanted to be more peaceful.
Thaddeus overthrew Emperor Oracle,
but was then killed by three
who had been bred to be
the strongest member of their race.
Up to that point
thrived, then became regent until he could
locate Argyle's son and heir.
Because amongst their people,
like breeding is more of an obligation
that it is something that they do for fun.
Oracle had a son,
but he was raised by his mother
and they lost track of the child.
When all the chaos started happening.
The military might civil war,
the war itself decimated their people
and while they were still rebuilding,
they were hit with another one
two punch in the form of the scourge
virus, which was a biological weapon
engineered by the coalition of planets,
is a way to fight the Viltrumites
and stop them from conquering
the rest of the universe.
The whole reason why they created
the Scourge virus is because literally
there was no weapon or other person
who could stop them in the universe.
Only about 37 members of their entire race
survived in the entire universe
in Thragg, trying to help rebuild his people
basically told all the Viltrumites
that survived have as many children
as you possibly can, inserted
their current method
of taking over the universe
by interbreeding
and creating hybrids on different planets
and then taking over the planet with them.
That's what's happening during the events
of Invincible Season one.
You're seeing that happen on Earth.
It was through
way of one replenishing their ranks,
so to speak, like keeping their race alive
because they thought
they were on the verge of dying out.
So they literally just start interbreeding
with the rest of the universe,
but also because it really only takes one
vulture mite to conquer an entire planet.
Having two of them means that they will
definitely conquer the planet.
The idea during Invincible is
that Mark is the rogue who decides
that he doesn't want to do that.
What if we didn't conquer Earth,
which creates
a lot of the drama of the series
and a lot of the conflicts and wars
that you'll see play out in future
seasons, Mark, versus dragging
the rest of his people essentially.
Eventually we find out that
no one Omni-Man is our gold son.
He's that missing heir that went
into hiding during the military might.
Civil war, making Mark invincible.
The character, the next heir
to the throne of the Viltrumites Empire.
But the reason why Wragg is the main
antagonist of the series
is because he has his plan
for the viltrumite people.
We are conquerors. We are going to conquer
the rest of the universe.
And on the other side
you have the coalition of planets
like Alan, the Alien,
all of these other people
that want to stop them from doing that.
And Mark
also trying to stop the Viltrumites,
from destroying everyone on Earth,
everyone he loves.
And like I said, the only thing that can
really kill a vulture might technically.
I mean, there are things that could
get pretty close to killing them
would normally be another vitrumite
Which is why Invincible Mark's
character is so dangerous
to ragnar's people,
which is why they hate that idea so much.
They don't want another vulture
right out there who would oppose them.
Now, there's a lot of stuff that happens
in the story
before Schrag becomes a big character.
The way I think they'll play out
is they'll send conquest
for most of season two,
and that'll be like a lot of the season.
And towards the end of that, we'll see
drag show up because he really doesn't
become a big character
until after the Conquest storyline.
We got a little teaser
for Conquest during season one.
He is another really badass
member of their race.
A lot of the season two will be Mark
reckoning
with the legacy of his people
in the aftermath of season one.
Like immediately after, people are like,
Wait a minute,
you guys were the villains the whole time.
And Mark just has to wade through that
while also dealing with continued
threats from the villain, from Empire
like Conquest and other characters.
Like, that's just the beginning.
There's a whole bunch of stuff
that we don't need to get into right now
without getting into spoilers too far,
depending on how many issues they cover
during season two, I think they'll cover
all of Conquest storyline.
Like I said,
and finish that around the finale
and then Spragg will show up
towards the finale
and be a much bigger character in Season
three and beyond.
Robert Kirkman did tease
that he would be adding new Canon material
for the episodes,
So there'll be stuff in the episodes
that didn't appear in the comic book
just because if they only did the comic,
they would burn through it
in like three seasons.
There are only 144 issues
in the original comic book.
It's kind of the same situation
with George R.R.
Martin in House of the Dragon
in the Game of Thrones universe.
The House, The Dragon story
that they're adapting right now
only covers a little bit of book material.
So when they were writing
the season, George R.R.
Martin had to help them
create a bunch of extra canon material
and just expand on that.
I think the idea with the Invincible
Animated series is they'll go for five
seasons in towards the middle of that run,
like by season three, Season four.
That's probably when we'll see
the live action Invincible movie.
It'll be interesting to see how many
of the characters on the animated series
play their versions in live action.
I think that a lot of them can do that,
and I think that was part of the idea
when Robert Kirkman cast those people.
Marvel did that with the
What If series, where they tried
to have as many of the movie actors
play the characters as possible.
Now, it wasn't every single character,
but a lot of the animated versions
were done by the movie versions.
James Gunn also just made that big
DC Studios announcement about their big
DC chapter one, like their DC Phase
one of rebooted movies,
and they're also doing the same thing
with their new animated series too,
in live action,
where the movie actors play
both versions of the characters
animated and live action.
Like I said, though,
I'm not expecting a ton of throwback
during season two,
mostly towards the end of the season.
I think maybe a couple of teasers
at the beginning of the season two.
Everyone let me know in the comments.
Do do you want Jeffrey Dean Morgan to also
play the live action version of Drag?
I feel like he'd
actually do a pretty solid job.
Everyone click here for that
Brand new DC Studios trailer video.
Learn about all the new movies
that they're making Superman, Batman,
all the reboots, and click here for my
Full Invincible Season two trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.